All right. The very interesting discussions
over on the David Pakman show subreddit. You
can find it at David Pakman dot com slash.
Read it that's r e d d EITI.
More than nineteen thousand not a hundred
thousand of our viewers and listeners are
subscribed to the subreddit user Fye Lo 1927
posted about the Trump administration's threats
to sue states that don't lift pandemic orders.
That's not going to go well. And we've been
following that. We've talked about that a
little bit on the bonus show. We've also talked
about some of the other funny business that's
going on related to states and stay at home
orders. And what we were very quickly seeing
is that there have been consortiums of reasonable
states. So you've got one on the West Coast.
We've got one on the northeast. You've got
some others that are saying we don't really
care what Trump says. We're going to do, what
the public health experts in our states determine
we have to do. That's inspiring. And so far,
it seems like the threats from William Barr,
Trump's Justice Trump, say, gee, in the Justice
Department to start suing states has had absolutely
no effect whatsoever. Charlie Baker, a Republican
here in Massachusetts, extended the stay at
home an additional two weeks from May 4th
to May 18th. I do think we need to start figuring
out a by mid to the end of May how to start
opening up elements of society, both for economic
and mental health. But it's got to be done
safely. But there is no doubt that we are
not now ready to open. And I'm glad to see
that most or many governors are making the
right decisions. Despite Donald Trump's threats,
intimidation and posturing that is happening
on a on a nearly daily basis. That is good
news. Another post I spotted on the subreddit
is from Moutier Boy, who says for those who
think the virus might sway a Trump bist goes
on to say, I've seen a few posts and had a
few chats with friends where people seem to
think Trump is going to be negatively affected
by things like recommendations of unproven
medications. Well, not only is it not going
to affect his supporters. I think it will
be worse than that as more and more evidence
comes to light about potential harm caused
by hydroxy chloroquine being inappropriate,
being used inappropriately, look for more
than a simple retcon of how it was presented
by Trump and Fox. People are going to start
actively blaming doctors for having actually
prescribed them, even if they themselves requested
it based on what Trump said. They will fall
back on Trump pointing out he's not a doctor
and that it should be up to doctors to not
prescribe or make available things like this
without evidence. And what's worse is that's
probably fair. If you ignore the fact that
America has a for profit medical system which
pressures court doctors to do what their customers
sorry patients request rather than what's
in their best interest.
I don't have to agree with everything that
said there to generally concur. And we had
Rachele Bittar, coffer political forecaster,
on the program last week. She doesn't think
that Corona virus, by and large, is going
to be the difference maker in November in
the sense that Trump's handling of the virus
has been such that there are people rallying
behind him for his great job. Those people
were going to vote for him anyway. The people
that are rightly criticizing the disastrous
job he's done, we're likely not going to vote
for him anyway. And in particular, the way
the coronavirus will affect the election is
affecting turnout. If the virus is still spreading
or again spreading in wave two in the fall
in November, that could hold down Democratic
turnout because Democrats are more likely
to pay attention to what public health officials
are saying than Republicans. If there is vote
by mail in November as a result of coronavirus,
that'll be a decision made by individual states
that is more likely to boost Democratic turnout
relative to if it's in-person voting during
a pandemic. So the handling of the pandemic
itself, I don't know that that is going to
be a difference maker in the fall in that
sense. I agree indirectly. How we vote in
the fall as a result of Corona virus may well
be the difference maker, particularly in those
key swing states.
Everything from Ohio, North Carolina, Michigan,
Wisconsin, Pennsylvania, etc.. One other post
I want to look at from the David Pakman show
subreddit Reflex Point posted. Recent Fox
News poll shows Biden winning Florida by four
points. Not too recently. It was a toss up.
Sorry, I meant plus three. But Quinnipiac
shows him up for. Listen, I want to be very
careful. Polls. Are important, polls are newsworthy.
It is our way to kind of figure out where
the wind is blowing. But I don't want any
poll, no matter how lopsided, one way or the
other, to prevent someone from voting in November
safely. Vote by mail if that's what's determined,
it has to be because, you know, we actually
have other. But Biden is up one in a Texas
poll. Now, admittedly, that's a peopIe people.
Those terms tend to lean a little bit to the
left. Trump is now up by I'm sorry. Biden
is now up by several points in North Carolina.
There are numbers coming out of Florida that
are really not good for Donald Trump. It would
be a beautiful thing if Donald Trump is absolutely
crushed in November. It would be the right
thing if Trump were absolutely crushed in
November. I'm not optimistic that that's going
to happen. I believe that if Biden wins, it's
going to be close and Trump supporters are
going to say it was rigged and it's going
to be a real fight. But there is no question
that there are polls right now that should
be red flags for Trump. And in fact, we know
that they are red flags for Trump because
he recently threatened to sue his own campaign
manager over the fact that he's losing in
a bunch of polls. And that's what we're going
to talk about next. Make sure you join the
discussion. I want you participating in these
discussions on The David Pakman Show subreddit.
Find it at David Pakman dot com slash r e
d d i t.